Oh
I'm glad I have a journalistic education
a journalism degree and of work to
journalistic outlets and for me what's
most important is that I still respect
the journalists there's a lot of
Hollywood publicists who like to have
power over journalists and like to
intimidate journalists I've never been
that way even if I'm in a situation
where I have a superstar that doesn't
mean I can't be courteous and nice to a
journalist because we're all trying to
achieve the same thing okay and I'm
trying to make friends not enemies out
there in the world what I've learned is
speed integrity kindness and you know I
had a client recently who was getting a
divorce and this client said to me we'll
just lie and i said i will i will say
i'm not going to comment on that because
it's a private matter but I said I'm not
lying my reputation is something that
I've achieved over many years in this
business and I'm not going to take 30
years and throw it away when your
husband's living in a hotel everybody
knows it you know so you you really have
to understand that your reputation in
your integrity are what you have and and
people know don't think journalists
don't talk to each other don't think
they don't know who the nightmares are
versus the people who are smart and it
goes back to my first job in PR why did
I get into PR people weren't reading my
magazine and I thought all you got to do
is read the magazine I look at that
today I look at people my office I'm
like if you want to pitch somebody in
the LA Times you don't call the editor
in chief of the LA Times you say well I
want to be in the calendar section and
this person writes about TV and this
might be the right person because they
cover this particular nuance you have to
do your work and you can't be a good PR
person without being a good consumer of
media and for my friends who are
journalists I would say not all PR
people are flax a lot of us have a lot
of respect and a lot of integrity and a
lot of professionalism and give us a
break to and communicate with us like we
communicate with you if somebody doesn't
return my email or a phone call I get
frustrated the same way they would if I
didn't return there's and we sort of
need each other it's not going to work
for either of us as well without each
other i promise you i think there's
there's one misunderstanding out there
and that is that young people don't care
about the news i think the opposite is
true i see the young people in my office
and the young people that i know online
on the web going to TMZ going to Perez
Hilton almost multiple times per hour in
a way where we our generation would wake
up or eat the newspaper and go on with
our day and watch the news at night so I
wouldn't mistake it for a lack of
interest I think it's really the vehicle
and it's it's like the trains back in
the early part of the last century they
made the mistake of thinking they were
in the train business and not realizing
they were in the transportation business
and I think newspapers have to
understand they're not in the newspaper
business there in the news dissemination
business and if you're the Chicago
Tribune or the New York Times yo you're
losing some advertising you're losing
readers and you have some real
challenges but at the same time you
bring some things to the table in terms
of history in terms of credibility that
these bloggers can't compare to and you
have to play To Your Strengths and there
may be some painful times but I don't
think they're going away I think they
may reincarnate themselves I think they
will come out in new forms when I'm
doing a campaign it really depends who I
want to reach if I want to reach older
more traditional people i'm going to go
for print and traditional broadcast if i
want to reach young people i'm going to
be viral there and foremost campaigns
it's like it's like food you don't just
want to eat meat or you don't want
vegetables you don't want carbs you want
to mix it up as I as I go
promote my book I have a mix of online i
have a mix of radio i have a mix of
print i have a mix of broadcast i have
social networking you want a pretty
balanced diet out there to reach the
broadest possible audience I think the
New York Times is going to become
something you read on your your personal
computer device that is your phone and
your ipod and all these things at once
and I think they're going to have to
adjust to this reality at the same time
there are people who are never going to
be happy unless they get the paper on
their front steps or they buy the paper
at the newsstand and that's why we're
going through this transition I think
what kindle has done for books really is
the future of books it's too expensive
to print things anymore it's bad for the
environment to print things other than
my book which is good for the
environment but most books most
newspapers it's bad for the environment
you read this thing for a half hour you
throw it in the garbage and you start
again there's a lot of waste there and I
just think economically we're not going
to going to be able to afford it but I
don't think we're at the place we need
to be where you have a beautiful eight
and a half by eleven reader that has
everything clear and it's thin and it's
transportable I think we're just a few
years away from that and I think that's
when the New York Times is really going
to understand what their future is as
well as the Chicago Tribune and the LA
Times
you know it's interesting there's a very
symbiotic relationship Sarah Palin kept
complaining about the media during the
presidential campaign and she said she
wanted to operate without a filter well
Hollywood celebrities have been starting
to do that Owen Wilson had a suicide
attempt last year and his first
interview when he came back was done
with his director and I think it was
done on myspace or facebook where he did
an interview and that way he didn't deal
with the traditional journalists however
traditional media outlets still got that
story out there after he did the
interview and in my own PR life I work
with Al Reynolds who is a college
professor and the financial expert
probably well known for being married to
Star Jones and we were approached by
every mainstream media outlet in the
world to do the first interview and I
knew they would sensationalize him I
knew they would sleaze him so we
conducted our own series of interviews
put them on YouTube and then released
him to the mainstream media and you know
we needed the mainstream media or we
wouldn't have gotten out there we were
very journalistic in the way we
approached the questions and answers
with him we asked all the tough
questions in the outlet would would ask
us which is why we didn't face a lot of
criticism from it so I think they work
together and you really have to
understand that they work part and
parcel with each other and it's
important to understand what's going to
play with mainstream media and what you
can get away with on YouTube and myspace
and some of these social networking
sites